In July,
former vice president,
Mike Pence was campaigning in Iowa where questions quickly turned to Donald
Trump and January 6.
If it wasn't for your vote,
we would not have Joe Biden in the White House.
I know by God's grace.
I did exactly what the Constitution of the United States required of me that day.
And I kept my Mike Pence and Donald Trump were completely an
odd couple that worked very well together.
You know,
I love Mike Pence.
I think he's great,
don't we?
Then came January 6th and it all all crumbled
much of Pence's testimony and contemporaneous notes are at the heart of the
justice department's case against Donald Trump and his alleged crimes committed
in a desperate bid to stay in power.
He was not only my president,
he was my friend.
That tragic day in January will always be a day
of great sadness for me.
Here's what the latest indictment against Trump tells us about how that relationship unfolded
after the 2020 election and what it could mean for the next one.
Trump chose Pence as his running mate largely to shore up more traditional Republican
voters.
He pulled in a lot of people that were skeptical of Trump that felt more at
ease.
Having Mike Pence at his side,
Pence certainly deserves some credit for Trump winning the presidency.
And during the administration,
they found that they worked pretty well together.
A lot of people were sort of still kind of scratching their heads.
How these two guys get together.
And Pence stood by Trump throughout numerous
controversies.
When Trump was president,
they got along and by all accounts up until leading up to
Trump losing the election.
Once Joe Biden was projected to win the election,
the justice department says Trump began a campaign based on false claims to change as many of
these states as possible from Biden wins to Trump wins.
Trump has denied wrongdoing and has accused prosecutors of pursuing him for political
reasons.
If you say something about an election,
they want to put you in jail for the rest of your life.
It's a disgrace.
Here's what the indictment says happened.
Once the efforts within the states failed,
the focus turned to Pence who as vice president was tasked with certifying the votes from the
electors of the electoral college.
And therefore the election on December 23rd,
Trump's plan became for the vice president to announce that because of the ongoing
disputes in the seven states,
there are no electors that can be deemed validly appointed and he would gavel in Trump
as re elected.
Two days later,
Trump brought it up to Pence in a phone call,
but Pence pushed back saying,
you know,
I don't think that I have the authority to change the outcome.
A few days later when Trump brought it up again.
Pence pushed back again saying he thought it was improper.
Trump told him you're too honest,
Pence is a very traditional Republican,
a lot of adherence to constitutional values.
That's just kind of in his DNA.
I'm sure it was a very tough thing for him to do.
I mean,
he was under tremendous pressure,
but I don't think it's that surprising that he took that stance as hard as it might have been.
The indictment says Trump pressured Pence several more times and Pence continued to say he
couldn't overturn the election and I hope Mike Pence comes through for us.
I have to tell you of course,
if he doesn't come through,
I won't like him quite as much in a final meeting on January 5th.
Trump grew frustrated and told Pence that he would have to publicly criticize him,
which made Pence's chief of staff concerned for his safety and he alerted the secret
service that night.
Trump continued the pressure tweeting.
If Pence comes through for us,
we will win the presidency.
There was a lot of in how Pence would act on the morning of January 6.
The indictment alleges an unnamed agent for Trump contacted a US senator to ask him
to hand deliver documents to Pence.
Prosecutors allege those documents were fraudulent certificates signed by fraudulent
electors in Michigan and Wisconsin.
When a Pence staff member was contacted about the documents,
the staffer rejected them later that morning after a call with Pence Trump delivered a
speech where he called him out claiming he could change the election outcome.
And I hope Mike is going to do the right thing.
I hope so.
I hope so because if Mike Pence does the right thing,
we win the election before,
you know,
Pence went up there to do his duty.
He released this statement laying out why he could not upset the
certification of the election.
And it set up this profound moment of tension in
which the vice president was going to go and defy the wishes of the
president before Trump finished his speech.
The indictment says a crowd began to gather at the Capitol back at the White House.
Trump tweeted that Pence didn't have the courage to do what should have been done.
One minute after Trump's tweet,
the secret service evacuated Pence to a secure location.
The attack on the Capitol delayed the certification for approximately six hours.
It wasn't until the early hours of January 7.
Th that Pence announced the certified results of the 2020 election in favor of Biden.
The chair declares the joint session dissolved.
The political fallout for Pence was almost immediate,
not just a threat to him,
you know,
physically as we saw him get yanked out of the Capitol but immediately
saw Trump Trump supporters turn on him.
Now,
the two are both running for president in 2024.
Pence definitely has got an odd line to walk because he's at once
criticizing Trump.
Anyone who puts themselves over the constitution should never be president of the United States.
And anyone who asks someone else to put them over the
constitution should never be president of the United States again.
But also,
you know,
saying how proud he was to be at his side for so long.
I'm incredibly proud of the record of the Trump.
Pence administration.
Trump is the clear front runner where Pence is hovering around 5% in national
polls.
Trump is so far ahead that he doesn't give too much notice to Pence.
But when Pence speaks out,
Trump is often will come back at him after Trump's indictment was announced,
Pence criticized Trump's actions after the election.
Sadly,
the president was surrounded by a group of crackpot.
Lawyers kept telling him what his itching ears wanted to hear.
Trump responded.
I feel badly for Mike Pence who is attracting no crowds enthusiasm or loyalty.
He didn't fight against election fraud.
He's going to get a lot of heat from voters who think that he costs
Trump another term for the time being.
I think January 6 kind of blunted any kind of future political aspirations for
Pence.
I said before,
I said when I announced President Trump was wrong about my authority that day and he's still
wrong.
I believe it with all my heart.